[Music]
everybody welcome to a special edition
of every damn day we just watched the
roast of Bruce Willis on Comedy Central
we left our little butts off and now
we're going to talk about it and as a
matter of fact one of us is actually
there in person
Chris cotton what was that like tell us
about it it was fun no the roast was fun
I'm be honest which was my first roast
ever attending I expected a roast to
come out they did not serve any roast
you expected like a pig on a spat the
spread was a little weaker than I
thought was the roast was delicious and
that by that I mean the joke
metaphorically delicious
jokes look like a pretty pretty classy
event black-tie right it was a good you
looked good Chris I would sleep with you
sometimes you just need to tell your
co-workers that you would sleep with
them that's just nice Chris has being
secured written on that cover which is a
good thing to be at the roast by the way
I'm gonna throw up some clips we're
gonna talk about it I think we should
start out with the roastmaster general
himself Jeff Ross showing how it's done
give it up for our next Secretary of
State my man Dennis Rodman
you think kim janghoon is a nice guy and
he thinks you're Scottie Pippen that's a
great job what what what do we love
about that job what do we love about the
job I'll tell you what I love about it
and I think they say about comedy is
that it's great to dissect it keeps the
joke but there's something about the
specific of Scottie Pippen that he's
like just well-known enough but not too
well-known like it's way funnier that he
said Scottie Pippen rather than like
Michael Jordan or something like that I
don't know if this is like lore if I
heard this from somebody I clearly I
heard this from somebody else but
apparently Kim Jong moon did want
Scottie Pippen oh yeah
and then he Scottie Pippen was like no
and so like they came to Dennis Rodman
they were like please go to North Korea
right I think the US government stepped
in and they were there cuz you wanted
like Jordan and they're like can we get
him Pippin and then they're like Rodman
I'll do it yeah just go to North Korea
the government is involved in that all
right the next clip usually throw that
up for Edward Norton is here
everybody edy looks to me like if a
marionette became a boy and then that
boy became an asshole right
short and sweet from Nikki Nikki one of
the best Roasters out there she's so
funny what what about her style is so
great what do you guys like about that
job she was like very open about like
I'm not friends with Bruce Willis I'm
here to dump on everybody here and then
just did a great job of it and it's like
that's wonderful that's what you want
from like the comedians on the dais and
like not the friends you're like we love
you so much it's like now you're bald
and old I also like Edward Norton's like
kind of faux like when when she called
him out he's like oh who me how
unexpected does he look like a
marionette because like his limbs are
loose I that part I was like how does he
look like a marionette maybe all the all
the strings that are attached to him
that he carries around with him
everywhere this was planned earlier we
lifted
I stole a Natasha's joke hero I set up
myself I was I was trying to thank you
how to throw this back to her what do I
do
the pros make it look easy but when
you're trying to set yourself up whoo
baby Ainsley play that next clip I've
heard words here tonight that I have
never heard before like lil
and rel lil rel I'm glad you're here
because I've been meaning to apologize
for calling the police about your
barbeque
Cybill Shepherd kind of this sneaky
attack very funny
really did you think not a joke just
sure I feel like she disrupted a nice
barbecue I imagine it's a reference
specifically to the one woman who became
the mean do you I think the referencing
race relations in America I think Nikki
Glaser's roast of Edward Norton was
really good okay because I was seated in
person and he does look like a
marionette cuz he's got little strings
attached to his I cut that too the
earlier section great well as Natasha
just demonstrated and as Ryan just
burned burned me it's pretty fun to
roast people so now everyone in the
comments I might regret this but in the
YouTube community section we're asking
you to roast us don't be cruel be clever
be clever and we'll read our favorites
on the show tomorrow Hannah wasn't in
the studio today because she was in Los
Angeles doing some reporting here she is
with Nikki Glaser talking about the road
[Music]
hey I'm Hannah I'm here with Nikki
Glaser and we're talking about the roast
of Bruce Willis how do you feel about it
how did how do you think Bruce took it
oh my gosh well I couldn't tell because
I was behind him the entire time like
staring at his head but I saw him moving
a lot in in ways that I was like oh he's
laughing or he's having a seizure but I
think laughing I assume the highlight of
the night for me not that you asked
no I loved enough um it was sitting next
to Edward Norton we just had so much fun
in commercial breaks like just talking
and like having fun and making
jokes and like roasting like in between
people's like it was it's like a party I
didn't know to me was gonna be there no
one told us it was such a surprise she
kills and all I was doing the whole time
was staring at her hair and being like
how is it so shiny she looks like a
horse that I want to do like therapy
with like I just want to pet her like no
she didn't look like a little bit of a
rose no no her hair her Mane was like a
glassy horse mane Jeff Ross crushed he
was my favorite set of the night besides
mine when he was saying that um Bruce
sued the Blue Man Group was my favorite
joke of the night Edward Norton set was
just like so different than anything
else I had ever seen at a roast it was
like a TED talk almost but it was like
one that I actually watched where
someone sends the Dean you go oh
actually watch that's that's what it was
Martha Stewart was just as scary as I
thought she would be and it's funny I'll
let you in on a little insider info I
had cut a lot of jokes about her that
word like super mean because I just
didn't want to go there and she I bet I
was like I bet she seems cold but she's
like a nice lady in person but then she
was cold so I decided to do those jokes
I want to relive it it was the best have
you talked at all what are you here for
Hannah all I want to say is that it was
such a fun night it really is what you
watch on TV in terms of like people
getting drunk and being hurt and
laughing and having moments off-camera
and on camera it's all real and that's
what I love about the Comedy Central
Roast is is it really is what you see is
what you get and what we're getting to
and I really feel like when you watch
this roast you experience that Thank You
Hannah for nothing yeah I knew I I think
I just lost my job
you can be my assistant
[Applause]
welcome to the roast of Jordan Mendoza
hey Jordan nice guy every but yeah we
love Jordan
don't we love the posture of a flaccid
hashtag little dick energy that's what I
say okay the posture just awful past so
that jokes not really landing for me I
think maybe part of it is like there's
truth and comedy and like that's untrue
I'm pretty good posture I do yoga all
the time I just want to say thank you
for the opportunity you know you really
are the roastmaster of Comedy Central so
truly it's an honor to be here today
okay here we go
Jordan calls his peepee and his
girlfriend never calls Wow okay my turn
great I just have a lot of them Jordan
do you can go ahead and say your thing
to the end Jordan it's great to see you
I'm really glad that you got rescued out
of that Thai cave is like Jordan is like
a reversible jacket he's got two sides
and neither of them is cool Jordan you
remind me of a Red Lobster because
you're cheap and you make me sick folks
Jordan is like diet dr. pepper he's
light and his parents are upset he's not
a real doctor
Jordan Jordan loves video games and I
can't blame him because if I were him
I'd also like to escape reality oh boy
oh boy oh boy
Jordan Jordan humor is like good health
insurance I don't get it
but in conclusion buddy I love you it is
a pleasure to work with you every day
I'm happy that we can work together
every day because it reminds me mostly
that I am NOT the worst one on the show
I I'm on it I like those jokes laughing
with you Bryan cuz I know you mean the
opposite whenever you say any of that
stuff so that was the roasted Jordan
Mendoza Ryan are you are you nervous
that I have asked people to roast us in
the YouTube community section well I
just don't think people are clever I
think they're just gonna be mean you're
they're gonna you're egging them on I've
yet to see YouTube comments that's
clever they're just like all shitty and
they're like you guys aren't funny and
you can't do this and I like this
skateboarding video you click there so
anything you can see all this than
you have distaste have you seen that
some of the skateboarding videos on
YouTube they're very good they're cool
they're so cool we will never be are you
kidding we're never gonna be as good as
it as an average skateboarding speed on
YouTube oh it's be more impressive have
you tried to do an ollie
yeah it's so hard really hard to do a
normal ollie without a trick I've yet to
see I've been to the park a lot and I've
yet to see any kid land a skateboard
trick let you watch for like an hour
and it's just all that I'm shooting the
board run to go get it and they pick it
up I would stop watching kids at the
park
check out the roses hopefully tomorrow
every damn day
[Music]
you